est-ce que vous connaissez le fairphone
c'est un téléphone que vous pouvez venir
démonter réparer par vous-même l'idée de
cette boîte qui est basé à Amsterdam
c'est de se dire qu'on peut venir
réparer son téléphone très facilement et
vous allez changer uniquement ce dont
vous avez besoin regardez ici par
exemple je viens faire fun et bien je
viens glisser mon doigt je peux venir
enlever la partie arrière et si j'ai un
problème avec ma batterie qui est mort
c'est bien je peux enlever ma batterie
venir la changer si j'ai un problème
photo je viens changer le bloc photo
ensuite je reviens je repose je reclipse
donc là c'est très cool parce que si
vous regardez les différents éléments de
ce smartphone on peut même venir à
changer l'écran qui est directement basé
ici elle a été lancé lui en 2021 ça a un
smartphone il y a 5G on a double sim on
les va aller sur un Android 11 et 36,3
pouces batterie d'un peu moins de 4000
maheur appareil photo de 48 mégapixels
bref c'est une fiche technique qui est
plutôt milieu de gamme et qui est
intéressant tout ce qui est intéressant
c'est la durabilité en plus il travaille
avec des matériaux qui vont pouvoir être
recyclés qui vont durer dans le temps
c'est un smartphone qui est garanti 5
ans je sais pas si vous connaissiez la
marque fairfall c'est le fairphone 4
est-ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce que vous êtes sensible à cette
démarche dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires et est-ce que vous
pourriez potentiellement venir acheter
un fairphone marquez moi ça